le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
fleuron du patrimoine réunionnais le
piton de la fournaise et sa route
réserve encore bien des surprises aux
visiteurs
il aura fallu 18 mois de travail et une
dizaine de partenaires pour mettre au
point la nouvelle application volcan de
la fournaise
grâce à ce guide virtuel touristes et
réunionnais pourront découvrir ou
redécouvrir cette route emblématiques à
travers ses multiples facettes humaine
historique botanique et géologiques
[Musique]
je voyage sur la route du volcan
commence
[Musique]
ah bon guidé par la voix d'un compagnon
virtuel la famille céleste s'aventure
sur un volant l'alcool
[Musique]
mais 64 heures du matin le village de
roches kahn est au coeur de la vallée de
la rivière des remparts est encore
endormie cheminer à travers les
millénaires d'histoire humaine botanique
et géologique du piton de la fournaise
voilà l'idée au coeur de cette
application mobile est une première du
genre à la réunion
[Musique]
vous allez voir ce scénario
d'interprétation aussi il fonctionne
toujours en doublon c'est à dire une vue
vers l'arrière vers le passé vers le
volcanisme anciens donc le piton des
neiges avec les hautes plaines pointe du
couteau vers l'avant
sauf qu'à chaque fois on a tous double
langage vers le passé et vers l'avenir
interactif éducatif et ludique
l'itinéraire est téléchargeable sur tous
les appareils mobiles
il est aussi disponible sur des
tablettes à l'accueil de la maison du
volcan
aujourd'hui rond je pense que c'est
nécessaire d'aller sur des technologies
a pour permettre à chacun via leur
smartphone il dira des tablettes comme
celle là de pouvoir découvrir autrement
à leur rythme à leur façon là c'est trop
dur quand et ça permet au tourisme et à
l'ensemble des publics donc les
réunionnais bien sûr pour des
s'approprier encore un peu plus cette
route dure sans l'application volcan de
la fournaise s'inscrit dans un projet
plus vaste de revalorisation des eaux de
l'île
[Musique]
ça va permettre à tout le public que ce
soit les personnes âgées les scolaires
les adolescents toutes les familles
réunionnaises aussi les touristes qui
viennent nous voir de découvrir
différemment cette route en s'imprégnant
de toute une histoire
nous devons aujourd'hui trouver des
projets innovants pour vous voir
découvrir la réunion de manière
différente aujourd'hui sur le volcan
demain ça pourrait être ailleurs
[Musique]
le département lot nf la cité du volcan
et le conservatoire botanique de
mascarin ont tous collaboré à cet
ambitieux projet afin d'offrir au public
une expérience unique
[Musique]
wes ça peut permettre d'avoir des
endroits que les gens ne connaissent pas
forcément parce que sinon il ya des
endroits où on passerait sans eau sans
s'arrêter en fait s'en rendent compte
qu'un cheval a profité il ya des moments
c'était facile et les moments si
difficiles à s'adapter folie il faut
bien l'écouter le texte art en faire une
cuisse mais sinon les petits cuisses
comme ça sont très très bien on apprend
beaucoup de choses
c'est un peu magique c'est un truc qu'on
voit qu'une fois dans sa vie qu'on peut
voir qu'une fois dans sa vie
[Musique]
pour
l'application volcan de la fournaise
c'est un itinéraire en 12 étapes
géolocaliser allant de bourg murat au
pas de bellecombe
elle contient des indications de point
de vue des informations géologiques
historique et botanique ainsi que des
quizz et des vidéos
le guide virtuel est téléchargeable
gratuitement sur tous les appareils
mobiles tablettes smartphones ou
disponible sur des tablettes en location
à l'accueil de la cité du volcan au coût
de 5 euros pour retrouver les différents
liens permettant de télécharger
l'application rendez vous sur le site du
département au www.cn.ca
4 point fr
[Musique]